bouncer is dragged down teamliquid
stands three verses five and a hundred
thieves head right back into the pit
they still have to worry about ex mithi
smiting this they don't have vision just
yet Oh late at the trying to get some
gear Baron what quarter HP very very
middle I said he wanted to go over the
wall
[Applause]
imagine going from back-to-back
relegation tournaments and fighting for
survival in your own league to winning
the entire thing well you don't have to
imagine
I'm Colin McNeill and today we're
talking about team liquid's 2018 na LCS
spring split run now if you're a TL fan
already I don't need to tell you the
boys in blue have not always had it easy
that's why our story starts last year in
two very unsuccessful splits for Team
Liquid for Team Liquid we've got another
set of roster moves to introduce to this
team they need to be able to beat a team
that's at the bottom of the standings
like Team Liquid the TL for them it's
it's back to the grind
[Music]
but things were looking up in 2018 first
teamliquid secured that coveted
franchise spot in the new league and the
hype surrounding doublelift poll belter
impact x mithya no lay men the team was
coming in hot to the spring split and at
least at first it did not disappoint
zero to liquid as the chase continues
they're all gonna turn in fordable
thanks to VOA's oh the world getting
revenge get it get it is X team has like
young FOP Sierra got a lot of time left
to go the staff watch Mike Jung is down
Alistair next up the structures being
destroyed and under 30 minutes liquid
gonna shut down TSM in the first game of
the split in top lip get revenge an
assault team off season funny
spent by teamliquid as they take down
the defending champion old tales as
blank ears are gonna for the gate here
I'm not way thought man son lemonade sir
in the middle always on the back
doublelift empower people in his eyes he
friends him down but now a katie and
everybody is a back line stop ellipse
has the entire enemy team in his eyes
and TL is just dog piling on top of
optic teamliquid completely steamrolling
this game this is gonna be the fight for
liquid there aces you just turn each
member of pops again to that pin cushion
double if and the rest of the team now
dogpiling again on the optic after the
algebraic bulldog for very low as the
fight almost turns in the favor of a hop
dick but you look back at the health bar
as a team liquid and that's the new look
of team liquid one of the big super
teams this year fan the rest of the
members aren't going to be rounded to
get away and the age comes in off the
triple kill purple belt can they beat
their own record by two seconds
Table eight wit with a fancy fast wind
better that's all she broke questions on
and liquid makes the game absolute
decimation of bus gaming therefore Team
Liquid looking so strong I don't think
you but this makes we're gonna dive is
why you know they from the opiates time
to die the time do it all back garb
ducts to indefinitely soil oh my mother
on a rampage take one take do so give it
a triple is perfect it may make it both
contracts goes down Petula Provenza
thank you phone no double if steal the
quadrant deep liquid for clean kill came
liquid a new that they take that gold
and Ghani is 26 24 and the whole team
liquid team is actually kind of
exceeding the expectation that they have
to start of the year they get one five
games and four of them have been faster
than anyone else
lead has one game so now it was week for
however if you remember that the shine
came off Team Liquid they face down
there first
oh and two week in the split and the
following weeks had them find
consistently inconsistent results gonna
try to get the damage done he might
fight birds and downs and I fresh bother
cutting with the take collects it up
he's back in the pool there you have a
team liquid on a struggle on the
struggle bus yeah at the moment no maybe
looking at coming into the week
tied for first and then having on o2
week
you can see impact devastate yeah I say
like Team Liquid is too good to look at
this bad are they slacking off in
practice they were losing that
motivation the next week and then they
come out and they look flat let damage
is enough definitely takes out some blue
and golden audience pile on Team Liquid
beam liquid they just Jordan have it
long take tonic smithy they get this tie
on they revive him I mean Team Liquid
has now lost right exactly they won
their first five of six so off we'll
really hot start and then here we go
losing four in a row well we had a
really really rough week of LCS and a
week of scrims
might be able to get it done done swept
it down it takes down the bookie goal of
Guardian the loser
[Applause]
and 4tl all the effort all the money
that was put into rebuilding this team
you know getting them this star started
line up and building their training
facility getting a new coach keep doing
all these things right that they have
put into this team to have them fall
short of playoffs would be nothing short
of back
and that is ridiculous will it gonna
pull in a thirty one minute women it's
been their first game of a patch for now
they have sole control of third place in
liquids back on top look at him trying
to run away with a little metal legs not
going to be much a nice night from super
double if he is so alone and jumps away
buy some time
Megan our camp in fines the big stun
against the wall they picked up one
they're going to find a second on the
unstoppable not for a long while looking
to lose his life as well doublet wins
that jewel 1v1 a fourth coming through
as well flag question losing control of
their composure but outside their base
race is gonna take it himself
near on the other side and says if I can
completely route him get him in the pan
he just goes for the ultimate flag and
drag out four double left and it's the
teleport in from impact he's in the
middle of the fight when it's not an
armbar they go right right
the bottle gets dropped by Olay the
fight the dance what a beautiful job by
teamliquid
as they take out each member of clutch
gaming
four double arrow again to kidnap one
back with the top it's gonna look pretty
takes down a light get to jump out know
the bullet polish doublet on a rampage
takes down the Cameo
the carriage is still up for a little
bit longer but they have two dogs so
much is my Bella this flash is where we
get the kill double it why is it on the
lemonnation
bring in one a double clap
right back in the steam is here too
here at DSM finally
Paul what is God make it to invite young
white have a brand identity no flat
shoes with the frame they're gonna find
shorty doc gonna disengage but the
frontline plus watcher means blah blah
and that's gonna be a certain that now
much to the relief of Team Liquid fans
everywhere in Week nine against cloud
nine they locked in that playoff spot
Team Liquid fighting to just earn their
spot to go into the postseason anyway
remember if you don't have a playoff
spot at the end of this week's games
you're done till summer Vic grabs it
into the backline it's licorice the dice
person staring gonna be taken down
second cloud9 is on the run but can they
even get away from enjoying the backline
it's sneaky to drop next and it's for
dead on cloud nine down to about 350 or
over is it Kenny stop em gets over chug
some alpha here comes
the fight continues well for liquid two
kills already doubled getting a double
for himself Estonia's pop will the
champagne into early tomorrow
that was such an audacious call from
cloud 9 as behind as they were with fair
enough opponents to force a fight and
open ground liquid calls their bluff and
reap all the rewards and they're just
going straight for the throw here since
Karen is up at 5:00 smoothie is coming
up but I don't know if it's gonna be
enough to time Nexus turret number one
is already down be warned ultimate gonna
be used yet again Nexus turret number
two under virus the Nexus itself now
avail team liquid making a statement
here and we died and they take down a
sub 30-minute win for TL a team that has
been fighting cold in Week nine coming
in and just tearing cloud nine apart
okay
so TL squeaks into the playoffs but they
get in facing down the likes of TSM
cloud nine one hundred thieves and echo
fox though things were not going to be
easy beautiful things about any sports
Irene it does not matter how bad you
have been doing if you make it to the
postseason you can win it all push back
a lot of all still available here scum
so I'm catch to rejoin the fray
attention the front line gets go to the
waveclear listings gonna be the big
surprise the two men shuffle hey guys
already liquid that was absolutely
beautiful spin sports to flash me if
folks said you can have the mountains
right we won you lost in Him who Nev
inverted his teepee to get it all join
the final fight fight of this body of a
team look up at a great glacial fever
he's gonna sign it all over him to kind
of reset the fight but again [ __ ] just
need to kite out safely her knee so
tanky you see son just the background to
try and pick up Olay but keep up the
fight in fact the number there you know
the feeling everyone's trying to get
away but to kill me I'll barely hold on
take another look at that dragon fight
is it also a leg you're actually zoning
so much in the backline and even
delaying his ultimate until a lot of
Spears were already stacked he think of
so much damage and still is able to get
out because the red couldn't come
through that ultimate so fantastic play
zoning there and then they just corral
them in the pits are picking up kill
break kids to be pretty irrelevant to
these teams as [ __ ] and it's gonna try
and end it with this Baron buff that
white and Nexus card is extremely low to
medium heat has me
and not really much left here but you
know to try and defend all Lambchop get
skinny again neither buzzer same place -
so propose they get shredded both is
only the phone man - oh no
might be enough doublet don't kill
Houdini foot [ __ ] actually darling got
the double kill I'll take this Dupree
firing on the other side of a triple
double live
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll get the double the daughter Kanna
finish him off as well
Phoenix dead too right Team Liquid they
can see that finals in Miami
personal tragedy struck doublelift
before the grand finals and there was
some question as to whether he'd be able
to play in them or not well he did play
and he was lights out in fact the
entirety of Team Liquid hit the rift
like players possessed they three owned
100 thieves sweeping them in the grand
final
thieves head right back into the pit
they still have to worry about Xfinity
smiting this they don't a vision just
yet related twice to get some here bear
at what
be very very hit that [ __ ] be wanting to
go over the wall
my god he gets out go to chasing him but
it's actually teamliquid who steal from
the electric days
from the veteran juggler on Team Liquid
memories hoops it from the side of
Xfinity remember has no flash to speak
of taking it very low not right back in
as PO Beltre comes up the Riu wall and
now it might be liquid whose
man
wait five to six acts such as these take
down smithy buh buh Beltre finds
vengeance for his bread
got it with the ultimate snag right
there or somebody actually pushes a pour
it in
mm opens up the curtain call another
great shuffle Cody son is down after a
mood likely to follow the deadly
flourish from downtown a poem Beltre
grabs the second bow got a minion wave
they work their way towards the Nexus
turrets Ryu is gonna be knocked up in
the air the ordinal comes through the
mid laner flashes away impact having to
fall back the turret still dropping
Dunlop gets himself back with rocket
jump as meteors on the frontline can't
find his way towards anyone gonna be
stunned out lockdown beat down yet Oh
dead double it grab the kill on that one
as the turret drops in sync with it they
continue to push the powered up minions
from the banner of command leading the
way and Paul Beltre again and to the
frontlines to make sure this fight goes
the way of Team Liquid Sunday taking
very low as expensive or an eternity and
a half the Nexus is exposed that thieves
are on the retreat and liquid is looking
to take this to match point they can
stick around with the Bob their gun
be able to go ahead able to find the
boat ditch draw is Ryu and that's one of
your carries already out of the mix run
hundred thieves in some trouble going to
be taken even lower Africa already taken
down it's a double for double limped and
the thieves are dreadful liquid will
look for the wind right here 24 minutes
on the clock this is one of the fastest
series ever a double kill for double
with Ryu is the last man standing we
shall not stand from
they go off into the final stage
tourists together liquid or your North
American LCS spring split champions
harmonious hoist of the trophy
tidy up the team what a moment for these
guys how much they've worked for this
this split we talked about how those big
offseason roster moves everyone was
hyped about him things looked a little
rough along the way but they rallied
they took down some of the top
contenders during playoffs and they
found the wind today and that's how they
did it
that's how Team Liquid broke their curse
they wore forth anymore they raised
their banner lifted the trophy and
became the fourth ever team to win na
LCS the fourth [ __ ] it's time to make
building your champions easier
introducing the score esports new builds
calculator which allows you to plug in
items and runes to figure out which
builds give you the best stats the new
builds page also gathers information on
what the top players and your favorite
pros are building so you'll be able to
try them out yourself take control of
your champion and try out the new
feature on the score esports build
website by clicking on the link in the
description below
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]